this is a digital ad content producer it
sort of stuff we put on sky a mighty
hive is an ad programmatic media
planning and buying company so the two
things but we're driven by data first
party data so consumer data first party
data we can lined up lay our hands on
and that drives or fuels the digital
content and the digital media planning
of us so what are the gaps in your
portfolio what are you looking to buy
well I'd like I'd love to have some
first party data assets that's consumer
information but I think that the two
legs that we have in content and
programmatic at the base of the business
so we have the building blocks in place
as I say I'd like to add data edits but
we're doing we will be doing to infill
and I'm fair to call them infill because
they're actually important in their own
way first in Latin America and
programmatic and secondly in digital
content in again in Holland around media
months which is based in Amsterdam which
is a burgeoning City in this era brexit
or number exit so the key thing about
what you've just said though is that
this is all exclusively digital it's not
going to be by that stage for a purely
digital a unitary structure faster
better cheaper that's those are the
basic principles around with first party
data driving content and media so we're
in the sweet spot of the industry that
the digital part of the industry was
about 200 billion of volume out of a
trillion if you call it with the old
stuff and the new stuff all 500 billion
of the old stuff so roughly 40% share of
advertising is now in digital and if you
look at advertising and marketing
services is about 20% big clients are
spending about 20 40 percent of their
budget on digital so we're in the sweet
spot it's growing at 20% a year whereas
the industry is only growing at 3 or 4
percent but does that mean that
traditional advertising is dead I mean
there's a column in The Telegraph that's
more not this is the year that
traditional commercial television
advertising goes into terminal decline
well I don't know that terminal decline
I don't know whether the problem is as
big as it was with newspapers or analog
newspapers but certainly
free-to-air television network
television is under pressure we're
seeing degradation audiences on both
sides of the Atlantic of
two or three percent a year so it's not
as bad as newspapers but it is there now
screen time ironically has grown you
know I think about six hours a day
average users in America are using
screens so it depends how you define TV
if you define TV as free-to-air or
network you're seeing not terminal
decline but you're seeing compression if
you define screen time as including
digital and everything digital growing
and growing correct we're at rapidly so
in our own case mobile viewing of
advertising and programming is you know
growing violently along with data which
is growing violent in terms of what we
can capture so these areas of very big
growth areas for us now in your major
results you've just published pre-tax
loss of nine point 1 million profitable
last year you're being extremely unfair
a bit like the FT no well if you look at
on a pro forma basis because we acquired
media monks in July and we acquired
mighty high or combine with mighty hive
on Christmas Eve if you Proform at the
results revenues were up by fifty
percent actually sixty percent at the
revenue line than fifty percent of the
gross profit line and our profits
doubled and in earnings per share terms
again if you pro forma for the year up
about three times so we're very pleased
with the progress and very strong and
it's a very from from little acorns oak
trees grow or from from peanuts and we
get to coconuts and Coco de Mer which a
double double-barreled coconut so a good
start but we have a long way to go now
you're off to advertising week Europe to
speak yeah shortly afterwards you in
Russia indeed you're pretty your
successor mark Reid yeah appeared at the
event yesterday I said the WPP you've
got to complex I mean he's killed off
some very well-known advertising brand
names well you know you know sort of
what is it simplicity is the hobgoblin
of small minds or something like that
I'm not sure sure that complexity is
necessarily a bad thing I mean
organizational neatness management by
spreadsheet I don't actually agree with
and the issue is a very interesting
point there are four major holding
companies you know put dense ooh and
have asked to one side for a minute two
of them are based in the US and
to another base in Europe why are the US
companies doing well relatively well and
why the European based ones doing having
a tough time I think it's because the
the European ones have consolidated
their brands too far have made it
simpler but when you add one and one
together as you well know or you may
find out one one doesn't necessarily
equal to it might equal one and a half
it might equal 1 it might equal actually
less than one so simplicity in and of
itself may not be the solution it may be
that you know it's better to be a little
bit messy the the companies in America
the two American companies are investing
in their brands and building their brand
so I think a short-term they do better
longer-term you know maybe simplifying
the structure is long-term better but
there's a period of dislocation which is
quite heavy
all right so Martin